tiens pour le plaisir je me suis dit ça
fait longtemps on se regardait pas un
petit sketch préféré de cyril c'est ça
et une caméra cachée qui en argentine
en fait les gens placent une boîte avec
un trou de doha le faire ça oui on va le
faire tout à l'heure quoi vous allez
voir on la refait gpg mon équipe radio
si on l'a retourné d'abord regarder ses
seins bien une boîte avec écrit surtout
ne regardez pas et qu'est ce qu'ils font
les gens regardent mais bien sûr regardé
sa maîtresse en argentine regarder
il
la connaissez j'ai perdu de vue j'ai
recherché ma offert en cadeau que vous
est offert c'est bon mais moi ça je
préfère peut pas passer des journées
entières à faire c'est justement ce que
vous avez fait je suis à la radio le
matin et j'ai mon équipe radio donc je
les ai amenés dans un endroit un peu
plus loin on a caché une caméra et je
leur dis venez faut absolument que je
vous parle d'un parent ils sont pas du
tout au courant et je redis venait faut
qu'on parle d'une émission qu'en
préparation tout ça et ils viennent tous
et au bout d'un moment
qu'est ce qu'ils font il regarda et
regarde regarde et j'adore absolument
qu'on arrive à surprendre et clément et
l'or clément on lui a dit le truc de tus
et de visa il s'attend pas à ce qui est
sa mère tu vas lire et il ya le il ya le
et lors il faut qu'on la fasse tomber
dans le truc à la fin
photomaton de doigts
ça permet de lancer le truc et ou quoi
mais c'est ca depuis hier chevaux
regardez rien je crois qu'en temps
normal et on s'use plus tard je veux je
vois pas ce qu'il y'a chacun qui doit
amorcer la position étonnante hyper
important et donc vous fait hyper garde
là dessus vous faites les délires
langues
c'est non
en tout cas les coordonnées de la main
moi je peux l'appeler mais il faut
absolument que tu fasses le truc à pau
béziers
c'est magnifique oui mais c'est surtout
qu'ils nettoient par terre dans que les
mecs ils se méfient pas à quoi ça bah
oui on me dit regarde pas dans un train
d'agir de raconter mon hd2 en fait j'ai
vu j'ai vu le tuyau je me suis à côté
ils ont tous bien préparé la prod 1